hey folks before we get into the review
i just wanted to give you all a light
spoiler warning all the footage i've
used is from the first few chapters of
the game and i've avoided story
specifics as much as possible however if
you don't want to know anything about
the story i recommend skipping ahead
using the timestamps below alright let's
get going
[Music]
the premise of xenoblade chronicles 3 is
a bit unusual but it sets the stage for
a 100 hour epic through a fascinating
world with strong characters and
rewarding combat xenoblade chronicles 3
may stumble from time to time
particularly in its dialogue but its
ambitious premise pays off with a
heartfelt conclusion xenoblade
chronicles 3 takes place in the world of
ionios where two warring nations kevas
and agnes are locked in an endless
struggle for resources these resources
are quite literally a matter of life and
death when a soldier is killed on the
battlefield their life force powers the
opposing factions feronis a giant mech
that doubles as a base of operations the
life force of fallen soldiers is
imperative for one side to succeed over
the other the population of ionios is
bred to fight and that's it from an
early age they are subjected to rigorous
combat training and expected to fight
for a 10-year term if they survive their
life term they are whisked away by an
all-powerful queen in moats of light
however most soldiers don't last 10
years this is where the protagonist noah
comes in noah is an offsear or a flutist
tasked with sending off fallen soldiers
through music
the world of xenoblade chronicles 3
doesn't follow the same rules as
previous entries and it's better for it
the unusual setting gives players a
fresh perspective to explore familiar
themes a major one of these is sacrifice
and how it can radically affect the
trajectory of someone's life while
xenoblade doesn't always tackle these
deeper themes with finesse it's hard not
to get swept up in the drama of it all
once the story gets rolling despite the
interesting premise and initial setup
xenoblade's biggest roadblock is how it
onboards players developer monolith soft
really throws you in the deep end and
the lack of a proper codex gives the
game a real sink or swim feel at the
outset the early hours are bogged down
by jrpg jargon like flame clocks
offsears pharaonises interlinks
auroboros life terms levenesses and so
on the game makes a noble attempt to lay
down the foundation of the world with a
poetic opening cut scene but that really
only scratches the surface you can
re-watch important cutscenes from the
menu but those only account for a
fraction of the story a lot of the
detail ends up in text-based dialogue
you can't rewind a quality of life
feature that i've come to expect from a
jrpg of this size and scope
what is it they need to stay alive
water
certainly
but what we need most
[Music]
is life itself
the story really doesn't come into its
own until about halfway through the
first chapter when you've been
introduced to all six party members the
characters are really what holds
xenoblade's narrative together some of
them don't make the best first
impression but by the end i cared about
each and every one of them since their
entire lives are built around fighting
there's a genuine sense of curiosity
that informs the party when they break
away from that cycle of killing and
explore the world with their newfound
perspective this gives way to emotional
reveals lighthearted banter and some
compelling backstory the highlight for
me is yuni a hot-headed foul-mouthed
party healer she isn't given much screen
time early on but as the story unfolds
she takes on a much more active role she
isn't afraid to call out injustices and
she regularly teases lands the
light-hearted sword-wielding brute for
his shoot first mentality it's a fun
dynamic but what makes uni truly
memorable is how she pieces together the
unknown parts of her backstory along
with the player and how it informs her
character as the story progresses
there's a particularly heartfelt
optional scene near the end of the game
that really shows how far she's come
over the course of her journey many of
the game's themes are embodied by these
characters as well lan struggles with
sacrifice and the ripple effect that it
can have on people mio the cat iradoran
offsear reckons with time and whether a
person who only has 10 years can truly
make a difference these themes are
generally interesting especially when
you factor in the unique state of the
world occasionally however the writing
undercuts some of these themes by over
explaining or revisiting them a few too
many times it doesn't ruin the story but
it does cheapen the message from time to
time
and that
will give purpose to the remainder of
our lives
a purpose to life
right okay
on an emotional level i could understand
wow really
i didn't say i agreed
i just see her point of view that's all
all right now
let's put a pin in the philosophizing
of course xenoblade chronicles 3 has its
fair share of plot twists as well i
won't spoil them here but some are
fantastic and re-contextualize the
entire series while others are painfully
predictable the predictable twists
aren't necessarily bad but the party's
reactions to these moments are
frustrating because they'll spend
minutes belaboring something obvious
that you saw coming a mile away
what really elevates the story is how it
weaves together loose ends from
xenoblade chronicles and xenoblade
chronicles 2. new players can still
enjoy the story but long-term fans of
the series will appreciate the direction
the plot takes according to series
director tetsuya takahashi the idea for
xenoblade chronicles 3 has been in the
work for nearly a decade and it shows as
much as i enjoyed the story xenoblade's
moment-to-moment dialogue can be pretty
rough what is it
not gonna change
huh
um
yeah i
hang on still gotta uh change my boots i
guess
your boots uh you'll need to hand with
those yeah
[Music]
it's hard to say whether the
localization or the writing itself is at
fault but it's difficult to overlook the
characters frequently state the obvious
the napon speech pattern is still
grating and some lines are so weighed
down by the in-game terminology that
they lose their meaning entirely even as
someone who plays jrpgs regularly i
found the dialogue to be overwritten at
best and cringe-worthy at worst at the
very least the english voice acting is a
bit stronger this time around especially
for the main party members this makes
some of the worst lines of dialogue a
bit easier to stomach now there are
still some weak performances but those
are usually relegated to side characters
who don't have much screen time when my
mondo have you
they'll follow you to the ends of the
world
[ __ ] that why don't you back off
combat in xenoblade chronicles 3 is the
sharpest in the series like previous
games xenoblade adopts the combat style
of an mmo but adds the flair you might
expect from a single player rpg each
class has a standard auto attack and
five unique arts tied to cooldown meters
as you progress you will unlock more
classes more arts and more equipment
slots to fine-tune your party
composition in total there are 23
classes each with their own playstyle
that can be mixed and matched across
your entire party for example yuni may
start as a healer but you may find she's
more effective as one of the five
different defender classes as you level
up classes with specific characters they
unlock master arts which the character
can use regardless of their class there
are some restrictions but this allows
characters to dabble in tactics that may
not be intended for their chosen class i
am well over 120 hours in now and i'm
still unlocking new master arts leveling
up different classes and uncovering
powerful new tactics it's a lot to
manage especially if this is your first
xenoblade but once it clicks it's hard
to stop thinking about at face value you
can boil down the combat to meter
management but that wouldn't do it
justice there's a tactile rhythm to it
that builds with every attack and
expands with every combo eventually it
crescendos into an incredibly powerful
chain attack that halts the battle
entirely before giving way to an
explosive ending these moments don't
happen by chance though positioning is
key timing needs to be impeccable and
forethought is a must if a party member
is knocked unconscious and there isn't
someone to pick them back up the chain
attack will fall flat and you'll have to
start the entire process over again
[Music]
thankfully if there's a mechanic you
don't understand xenoblade chronicles 3
has a deep and ever expanding tips menu
every time a new mechanic is introduced
whether it be in or out of combat that
tutorial pop-up is filed away in the
menu i wish this menu had better sorting
features but it's a welcome addition
considering that once you closed a
tutorial pop-up in xenoblade chronicles
2 it was gone forever while the combat
itself is fantastic the real
satisfaction comes from experimenting
with different party compositions and
streamlining various loadouts my
favorite moments in xenoblade chronicles
3 are when i'd get swept by a boss
adjust my party composition and rain
hell on that same opponent in a second
attempt
[Music]
it's a brilliant loop that really
hammers home the depth strategy and
malleability of combat if you notice
that your tanks are having trouble
pulling aggro you can tweak their
loadout or you can create an entirely
new tank build with a different subclass
it's an empowering system that can be
endlessly modified the menus themselves
are also a huge improvement over
xenoblade chronicles 2. flipping between
different characters changing classes
and swapping arts is a frictionless
experience and if you're the type that
wants to spend as little time and menus
as possible there is an auto load
feature that automatically kits out a
party member while this is a welcome
alternative for those who may not want
to manually equip every character it
didn't always yield the best results
when i did auto load a character i
typically had to go in and make some
adjustments based on the class i chose
but at the very least this feature gave
me a baseline i could work with
[Music]
exploration also feeds into progression
resources scattered throughout ionios
can be used to craft stat boosting gems
cook meals and complete side quests
while side quests offer material awards
such as money and accessories they also
improve the party's standing with
various colonies which is tracked in the
affinity chart as you explore more of
the world you will come across more
colonies the more colonies you assist
the more passive buffs noah and his
party will unlock these buffs range from
faster run speeds to increasing the
duration of meal effects what really
makes xenoblade's exploration so
satisfying is how it connects to
everything else both in terms of
narrative and gameplay you might be
collecting resources to craft a specific
gem but you notice that some of the
resources you've collected could also be
used to complete a specific side quest
completing that side quest could improve
noah's relationship with a specific
colony which could unlock a new buff
that makes getting around ionios even
easier if you can get around the world
more efficiently then in theory you can
scavenge quicker allowing you to
complete more quests and craft better
gems additionally some of xenoblade's
best moments can be missed entirely if
you don't take the time to soak in your
surroundings hero quests activities
marked with yellow exclamation points in
the menu are fully voice quests that
introduce a new class and party member
some heroes are introduced during the
main quest but a majority of them start
as inconspicuous side quests
monolithsoft's character design really
shines in these hero quests not all of
the hero characters are as cool as grey
the mysterious gun-toting bandit but
they are all given backstory and offer
new classes some of which can
dramatically shake up your playstyle
i'm sure
everyone has their own way of thinking
i'm not trying to say otherwise
in any case
there's a place for you on my
battlefield if you feel like joining
as well thought out as these systems are
though the setting itself is really what
steals the show xenoblade chronicles 3
pushes monolithsoft's open world design
even further than past games the areas
you explore are massive colorful regions
teeming with life both big and small
monolithsoft's mastery of scale is on
full display here once again
awe-inspiring landmarks like the great
sword can be seen from around the world
formidable beasts tower over your party
and roam the plains and vibrant
ecosystems stretch into the horizon the
world of ionios is a sight to behold and
a testament to the environment artists
at monolith soft this is all accompanied
by another beautiful score from yasunori
mitsuda and manami kiyota the music
confidently swings from haunting
lullabies to sweeping orchestrations
that flawlessly match the mood of a
scene or the tone of a region the flutes
are also more pronounced this time
around giving the music a more intimate
feel when the scene calls for it can you
really speak for them though
for someone nearing the end
huh
because i couldn't tell you
all we can possibly do is wonder what
it's like
what can one feel
contentment perhaps
or sheer horror
despite xenoblade's apparent beauty it's
hard not to feel as though the nintendo
switch's hardware is holding it back
watching grass filling just meters in
front of you is hard to ignore beautiful
vistas are soured by poor draw distances
and some rough textures make bland side
characters even more bland these issues
are present whether you play docked or
handheld more noticeable are the lengthy
load times and unstable frame rates
while both of these issues don't persist
throughout the entire game there were a
few isolated incidents that are worth
noting during one fairly standard side
quest i was hit with one to two minute
long load times between each
conversation additionally much later in
the game i was hit with a couple load
times that were so long i almost
restarted the game because i thought it
had crashed typically the load times
were pretty snappy so these moments
really stood out there's also a specific
area much later in the game where the
frame rate takes some noticeable dips as
it's optional there's a good chance you
may not even find this area but the 30
or so minutes i spent there were rough i
don't think any of these issues should
turn you off from xenoblade chronicles 3
entirely however
xenoblade chronicles 3 feels like the
game monolith soft has been trying to
craft for years while its dialogue could
have used an extra pass it more than
makes up for it with its wonderful story
and superb combat it's rare for a jrpg
to hold my attention for a 100 hour run
time but xenoblade chronicles 3 did it
with confidence
[Music]